welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farron cousins from ring of fire
once again filling in for david
you know
one of the things
that we have talked about a lot with
regard to the january 6 hearing
is whether or not
any of these televised hearings are
going to have any kind of impact
on the 2022 midterm elections
and according to former tea party
republican joe walsh who tweeted out on
thursday
no
they will have absolutely no impact here
is joe walsh's tweet
twitter world may not understand this
but january 6 and these hearings won't
make any difference in the midterms
the hearings are important and necessary
but they'll have zero impact
this november
it's kind of kind of a bummer right
i mean
way to come along and ruin everybody's
mood there captain buzzkill
but at the same time
i don't completely disagree with him
i do think
for the most part
and i'm struggling to say that because i
don't know how much i believe him or
agree with him
but i do think he's right
if these things do end up having an
impact on the 2022 midterms
i don't think it's going to be
a hugely measurable impact
right it may affect like a couple races
but i don't think it's going to affect
enough of them
to
stop what we all see is likely coming
which of course is republicans taking
back the house i i don't see it doing
that i don't see enough momentum with
this
i don't see enough you know
tying it into the other republicans
because the hearings of course are all
really about donald trump and his
administration
yes we've you know identified several
republican members of congress that were
involved
but even if we took out each and every
one of those people in the elections
republicans would still be poised to
take back the house so that is why i do
again kind of agree with what joe walsh
has to say
but then
the other but
is the poll numbers right
the poll numbers out there
are kind of contradicting it at least
right now
here's what they tell us nearly
two-thirds of us adults believe the
january 6 2021 riot at the capitol was
planned according to a new quinnipiac
poll poll found that 64 of respondents
believed the attack was planned and 30
believed it was spontaneous
okay
so it's influencing public opinion
which is great
i mean that that's the whole point of
all of this we want to influence public
opinion but not because we're trying to
brainwash them or you know push them
into any kind of political ideology but
because we want to influence their
opinion on the people who perpetrated
these acts
and there's a big difference between
those two
this is not a partisan political
committee as the republicans would like
to have you believe
this is in fact a fact-finding mission
and so far a lot of the facts that they
found have been very bad for the
republican party
so
the question is
could it
have an impact on the 2022 midterms in a
meaningful way and the answer is
possibly
in order however for that to happen
the committee's work
would have to focus more on the
republican party as a whole
you know not just paint donald trump and
giuliani and some of these other weird
little characters out there
as you know the only people
they would have to come back in and tie
it all in saying this folks
is who the current republican party is
and that's not the job of the committee
that's the job
of the democratic party
and that's where that disconnect exists
the january 6 committee has done great
work
i was skeptical of them at first didn't
think they could pull it off they have
they have proven me wrong and i am
grateful to them for it
but now is the time for the democratic
party to step up
because yes these hearings are impactful
yes they are changing public opinion
but the committee is not going to sit
there
especially with republican like liz
cheney sitting on there and say this is
who all republicans are they're not
going to do that and they shouldn't do
that either
they kind of should but they can't i
understand they absolutely cannot
because you will start to turn off
people
what the democratic party could do
should have already been doing
is turning some of this into ads
ads running on national television
channels all across the country
but they're not
the messaging
from the democratic party
needs to be that this is who the
republicans are not this is who trump is
not
this is who jim jordan is
this is who they all are
every one of them
yes use that language
yes i don't care if it makes liz cheney
or adam kinzinger sitting on that
committee angry
this is your opportunity
the public is paying attention to these
hearings millions of people have already
tuned in
the polls are shifting in pretty
significant ways i mean rather shocking
ways if you ask me
so seize that moment jump on that
opportunity
and put it in ads
put it in people's faces every day
tie every single republican candidate
out there
back to these people
because even if they didn't participate
they still vote with them
hell a lot of the candidates out there
running for office actually support what
happened that day they still support
donald trump
that's why you do have candidates by the
way like dr oz who have now shifted
their messaging to stop mentioning trump
as much
and you know moving back on to just just
the issues folks don't let them do that
don't let them get the upper hand tie
every republican in the country
to everything this committee has found
you do that you may have a pretty
significant impact on the midterms
but if the democratic party is sitting
there waiting for the january 6
committee to do this themselves it ain't
going to happen
that is not the job of this committee
and if they attempted to do that they're
going to lose all the credibility that
they have
this is on the democratic party they
could
do this
they should do this
but
if history is any indicator
they uh
won't
be doing that
i think this is the biggest discount
that any sponsor has ever offered on the
david pakman show this is crush organics
crush organics loves the show so much
they're giving my viewers 50 off their
entire collection of organic cbd
products when you use the code pacman
i'm the only show
where you can get this big a discount
that i like and for each sale crush
organics will donate 10 to the last
prisoner project that's a really great
non-profit helps to
free non-violent drug offenders and
reform drug laws very important and it
doesn't stop there anyone who uses my
code also gets a free jar
of cbd gummies or a jar of cbd topical
cream crush has only the best organic
cbd whether you're looking for oils
creams or edibles so that's 50 off and a
free jar of gummies or topical cream and
10 bucks towards creating real change in
our justice system go to crush organics
dot u s
and use the code pacman the link is down
below